ich bin der Meinung Deutschland ist ein
datenentwicklungsland das hat sich in
der corona-pandemie ganz deutlich
gezeigt und wir sind nach wie vor keinen
wirklichen Schritt weiter Staaten
Entwicklungsland heißt wir haben nach
wie vor keine geeigneten Daten um die
Pandemie oder weitere Krisen vernünftig
zu managen weil die Daten uns überhaupt
nicht die Wahrheit sagen was eigentlich
passiert ist sie oder was passiert sie
sind beschränkt auf den
Gesundheitsbereich wir wissen viel zu
wenig darüber was in der Wirtschaft
passiert was im Bildungsbereich passiert
welche psychischen Folgen Menschen
erleiden obwohl wir diese Daten
eigentlich haben könnten und noch dazu
kommt in den Bereichen wo wir Daten und
Studien haben werden uns diese Daten
vorgesetzt mit teilweise haarsträubenden
Fehlinterpretationen das geht ich nenne
nur ein paar Beispiele los September
2021 mit der Aussage der dritte die
dritte Impfung der Booster erhöht die
Schutzwirkung der Impfung um den Faktor
10 völliger Unsinn sie können einen
Schutz von 99,8% nicht verzehnfachen das
werden 9 1980 Prozent das ist nicht
möglich dann die Aussage jetzt im Sommer
Masken die mega maskenstudie 1700
Studien wurden untersucht der Nutzen der
Masken sei groß unumstritten und Geld in
vielen Bereichen schaut man genauer hin
waren es am Ende 13 Studien die
überhaupt nicht miteinander vergleichbar
waren ja die Masken wirken aber sie
haben eine relativ kleine Schutzwirkung
dann geht es jetzt wieder weiter im
Oktober 11 Oktober Tweet von Lauterbach
das Oktoberfest hätte die Inzidenzen
befeuert beweist wir haben den Anstieg
in München und Bayern in Bayern der so
hoch nach oben geht was völlig ignoriert
wird ist dass es im praktisch allen
Bundesländern ähnlich gestiegen ist
Aussage dann aber wir werden an einer
maskenpflicht in Innenräumen im Winter
nicht vorbeikommen da frage ich mich
schon ob nicht zuerst die Überzeugung
weil wir brauchen die maskenpflicht und
dann hat man sich die Daten passen
gesucht und der neueste uns in den wir
jetzt haben ist diese Studie die
angeblich zeigt dass die bivalenten
Impfstoffe gegen noch zu erwartenden
neue Mutationen helfen können auch
völliger Unsinn schaut man sich die
Studie mal genauer an dann ist
untersucht worden wie bereits existente
corona-varianten na klar andere haben
wir ja auch nicht wie da die Impfung
wirkt man sieht auch dort dass der
vivalente Impfstoff schlechter wirkt bei
verschiedenen Omicron Varianten
vielleicht minimal weniger schlecht als
die bisherigen
Impfstoffe aber auch da muss man sagen
wenn man dann noch mal genauer hinschaut
am Ende sind 12 Personen pro Gruppe die
untersucht worden sind das wird dann
wieder schön verschwiegen und da habe
ich das Gefühl uns wird vorgesetzt das
sei Wissenschaft das hat mit
Wissenschaft nichts zu tun also es
notiert immer mehr zu einer Pandemie der
Lügen und die Wahrheit bricht sich
tatsächlich ihren Weg sie haben es
völlig richtig gesagt ich finde es auch
faszinierend dass nicht mal 50 Prozent
der Patienten in den Krankenhäusern
überhaupt erfasst werden ob die geimpft
oder ungeimpft sind wie kann man dann
überhaupt mit Statistiken Arbeiten
beziehungsweise wenn dann wird es im
Privaten gemacht Vorbild Helios Kliniken
haben ihr eigenes impfregister angelegt
da kann man unglaublich im Studiengang
Kollegen hat dann aber von Charité und
so weiter geflissen ich ignoriert weil
das sind ja privat und die sind ja nur
am Profit interessiert dabei sind die
praktisch die einzigen die uns
vernünftige Daten liefern um zu
verstehen was in den Kliniken in Bezug
auf Corona eigentlich abgeht ihr Leben
das Problem ist aber wesentlich größer
als der Umgang mit Daten im Zusammenhang
mit der corona-pandemie im Hintergrund
steht eine ganz furchtbare Unbildung in
Bezug auf Statistik jeder stolz darauf
dass an der Schule von Mathematik nichts
verstanden hat und dass er das Fach froh
ist es nicht mehr machen zu müssen jeder
weiß von Statistik im Grunde nur den
dämlichen Spruch dass man nur der
Statistik trauen sollte die man selbst
gefälscht hat das glaubt man dann dass
mit Statistik immer nur verfälschen
umgegangen wird ab und zu kann man
natürlich doch Interpretationen sein
Argument stärken aber das ist dann so
wie es manchmal Journalisten in der Mund
gelegt wird ich werde mir doch eine gute
Geschichte nicht doch allzu viel
recherchieren kaputt machen lassen ja
warum
und einmal zum übelsten Beispiel geraten
dann immer wieder Talkrunden wo dann
jemand mit Fakten kommt und dann eine
abgewirkt mit dem Hinweis darauf naja
diese Fakten die interessieren uns
unsere Zuschauer nicht so sehr die
können wir jetzt nicht nachprüfen und
derjenige der sich bemüht Fakten
einzubringen er steht dann am Schluss
als ein begossener
Puderzucker
über 100 Jahren eins meiner
Lieblingszitate hat der Autor der
Zeitmaschine 11 Science-Fiction Outdoor
gesagt wenn wir mündige Bürger in einer
modernen technologischen Welt wollen
müssen wir Ihnen drei Dinge beibringen
lesen schreiben und statistisches denken
also den vernünftigen Umgang mit
Unsicherheit und Risiken haben wir bis
heute nicht lesen schreiben übrigens
Stichwort Vorlesen wir haben in
Deutschland 7 Prozent funktionale
Analphabeten Menschen die nicht in der
Lage sind einfacher Texte zu verfassen
oder zu lesen wem sollen die denn
vorlesen und auch das wird teilweise
wieder falsch dargestellt es gibt
übrigens eine schöne
Darstellung der Volkshochschulen von
denen ich eigentlich relativ viel halte
die das so darstellen über 50 Prozent
der funktionalen Analphabeten der
Menschen die nicht richtig lesen und
schreiben können haben Deutsch als
Muttersprache der denkt man oh mein Gott
deutsch ist es Risiko dafür nicht lesen
und schreiben zu können falsch wir haben
einfach nur sehr viel mehr Menschen mit
Deutsch als Muttersprache in Deutschland
das Risiko nicht richtig lesen und
schreiben zu können ist deutlich höher
wenn sie nicht Deutsch als Muttersprache
haben oder wenn sie ihren Schulabschluss
abgebrochen haben aber wozu kommt diese
Studie durch ganz klare Verdrehung der
Daten bis sie passen nicht lesen und
schreiben zu können
illetarat Analphabet zu sein kommt in
allen Gesellschaftsschichten vor mit
jedem Schulabschluss ist einfach eine
Verdrehung der Tatsache neben dem
journalistische ihre Verteidigung weil
es auch im Journalismus oft so ist man
recherchiert vielleicht in eine
bestimmte Richtung und dann merkt man
nee so wie gedacht ist es nicht Thema
gestorben muss
sie haben nur gesagt
und der Fall relotius hat schon
Wahrheit dabei ist tatsächlich müssen
auch die Medien durchaus ihre Bewohner
Berichterstattung
aufarbeiten stimmig vollkommen zu es war
ein Dänemark gab es den Fall das gab es
die Zeitung hieß extra beladet ich
glaube sogar boulevardplatz die haben
sich entschuldigt die haben gesagt
jawohl wir haben zu einem bestimmten
Zeitung angefangen praktisch nur noch
regierungsnarrative Regierungserklärung
zu übernehmen
nicht gefallen lassen dann kommt aber
die Entschuldigung der anderen Medien
Vertreter also ich glaube eine
Entschuldigung war eigentlich überfällig
in der Zwischenzeit vor allem auch von
Karl Lauterbach weil wie gesagt ich
glaube er macht wirklich Sherry picking
mit seinen Statistiken er sucht sich die
Daten raus die im gefallen und da
widerspricht ihm keiner dass er keiner
ist nehmen sie mal die Statistiken Weg
die könnten keine Überprüfen
der passen Satz hier in Spanien hat ja
gesagt so heißt ja auch sein Buch wir
werden einander FIFA zeigen müssen sein
muss man ja erstmal um Entschuldigung
bitten dann erst verziehen werden und da
würde ich dann doch noch mal Sebastian
Geißler Fragen mit Blick auf die Medien
da muss man ja auch selbstkritisch sein
was gibt es denn was die Medienhäuser wo
die um Verzeihung bitten müssen also man
hat sicherlich zu stark bestimmte Zahlen
z.B einfach übernommen verliert gar
nicht gefragt was bedeutet denn R-Wert
was bedeutet Inzidenz warum muss denn
die Inzidenz unter 50 bleiben jetzt
haben wir irgendwie wieder 1000 noch was
noch viel mehr Inzidenz ja man muss ja
sich klar machen was diese Zahlen auch
bedeuten und es gab ja so absurde
corona-maßnahmen das eine alte Frau
nicht mehr irgendwie auf der Bank sitzen
darf ein Buch lesen darf das ist so
grotesk oder Menschen wir haben sie noch
mal gesehen Menschen die verfolgt werden
von der Polizei im Stadtpark ich glaube
draußen
joggen ist doch was gutes für die
Gesundheit ja es kann doch nicht sein
das sind nämlich auch wieder Regeln
gemacht worden von Politikern die
offensichtlich sehr gut bürgerlich
wohnen die sich gar keine Vorstellung
gemacht haben offensichtlich was es
bedeutet wenn ich mit einer Familie auf
in einer Dreizimmerwohnung oder als
Single sogar eine Einzimmerwohnung über
Wochen mich irgendwie da zu Hause
anschließen soll das ja ich gehe sogar
noch einen Schritt weiter und sagt er
mit einem verziehen werden kann muss man
vorab zu geben dass man möglicherweise
nicht alles weiß und dass man unter
Unsicherheit entscheidet und nicht zu
sagen ich habe hier eine Studie und ich
habe paar Daten und damit ist die
Entscheidung alternativlos das ist
nämlich das nächste Problem zu glauben
weil ein paar Daten haben wird uns die
Entscheidung abgenommen oder wir gehören
die Entscheidung ausrechnen und es fehlt
aber dann der Mut der Mut als Politiker
sich hinzustellen ich treffe hier eine
Entscheidung auch wenn ich nicht 100%
sicher bin was richtig ist weil hier ist
ja das Gegenargument ich habe aus als
Vorbereitung für die Sendung heute habe
ich gestern einen großen Social Media
Post gestartet und da eigentlich gesagt
man müsste jetzt das mal aufarbeiten 2G
habe ich da jetzt Beispiel genommen weil
es für mich die härteste Regelung war
was ich fand für die Bürger und da
drunter waren aber wirklich 50 Prozent
Kommentare die gesagt haben warum ich
das jetzt wieder raushole das wäre
Boulevard clickbating man sollte das
jetzt nicht aufarbeiten was soll denn
damit erreicht werden und da war ich
schon schockiert und muss sagen die die
deutschen Medien schreiben gar nicht so
anders als die Bürger ist auch in Social
Media sehen dementsprechend glauben Sie
wirklich dass es aufgearbeitet werden
wird oder dass die Bürger überhaupt
wollen also wirklich die Frage möchten
die Bürger überhaupt das aufgearbeitet
ob die Bürger die das möchten sich unter
ihrem corona-kurs oder ein unter ihrem
Post überhaupt melden anderes Beispiel
und eine Politik die ich heute gesehen
habe Umfrage von der Welt welche der
ampelparteien die vernünftigste Politik
macht die SPD vier Prozent die Grünen
neun Prozent die FDP 42 Prozent naja
sieht man jetzt nicht unbedingt in den
Wählerzahlen ja also da kann man dann
sagen die Stichprobe die hier wohl
geantwortet hat ist vermutlich nicht
repräsentativ also die ist wohl nicht
das was die Menschen für bessere Daten
ich werde verbessere Daten und darauf
nicht allen Daten die man bekommt
insbesondere auf Social Media einfach so
zu vertrauen